Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour, je m’appelle
François Grand-Jacques
et je réalise des films.
Pour la création de ces films -
des reportages, des documentaires -
je suis souvent parti à l’étranger
dans des conditions qui sont à l’origine
de ma présence aujourd’hui devant vous.
Ces conditions, les voici.
J’ai, durant ces voyages,
très rarement dormi à l’hôtel,
c’est-à-dire que je dormais
chez l’habitant, comme on dit.
Pourquoi ?
La plupart du temps,
j’étais logé chez la personne
dont je venais faire le portrait,
ou bien je logeais à l’endroit
où le sujet du film se déroulait.
Par exemple, j’ai passé une semaine
dans un bidonville de Lima
pour faire le portrait de Sylvie Dumans
et son association Mano a mano, que voici,
ou j’ai habité dans un village
lacustre au Cambodge,
sur le lac Tonlé Sap.
Cette manière-là de voyager est
fondamentalement différente de l’hôtel.
Elle est souvent plus sympathique,
plus exotique que l’hôtel,
mais elle est aussi plus inquiétante
et plus dérangeante.
Pourquoi plus sympathique, plus exotique,
plus inquiétante, plus dérangeante ?
Est-ce que vous connaissez le kava ?
Homme 1 : Non !
(Rit.)
Non ? Personne ? Non ? Oui ?
Il y a du oui. Il y a deux « Oui ».
Pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas,
à l’ouest du Pacifique
se trouve l’île du Vanuatu.
C'est un pays anciennement appelé
Nouvelles-Hébrides.
C’est un archipel très retiré au large,
très large, de la Nouvelle Calédonie.
Avec Pierre Noël, mon acolyte de tournage,
nous passons quelques jours
dans une tribu du Vanuatu
pour faire le portrait
de Blandine Boulekone,
une femme incroyable,
qui a notamment travaillé à l’amélioration
de la place des femmes dans le pays.
La voici.
Le soir, quand on vit
dans ce village nivate -
c’est-à-dire du Vanuatu,
nivate, du Vanuatu -
on boit le kava.
Le kava, c’est quoi ?
Le kava, c’est une plante endémique du
Vanuatu, de Wallis et Futuna et des Fidji.
Le kava, on en fait une boisson
que l’on prépare en groupe.
Comment ça se prépare ?
L’idée est de mâcher une racine de kava
jusqu’à en faire une bouillie
dans sa bouche,
puis de cracher cette bouillie
dans une sorte de pot commun
où elle est filtrée par un tissu.
Et on boit ensuite ce mélange.
C’est une boisson total Covid,
absolument Covid.
C'est merveilleux.
Il faut quand même imaginer la scène -
je vous mets dans le noir pour ça,
je pense que c’est mieux.
Donc, vous êtes sur une petite
île au milieu du Pacifique,
devant un nakamal.
Un nakamal, c’est une sorte
de grande hutte traditionnelle,
très belle, faite de bois sculpté.
Vous mâchez des racines -
bon -
avec cinq ou six hommes à moitié nus,
ou dotés d’un étui pelvien, un grand tube
qui est fixé au niveau du sexe.
Vous êtes en cercle autour d’un grand pot
et vous crachez dedans,
tous ensemble -
mais c’est très sympathique -
des morceaux de bouillie couleur sable.
Et tout ça en n’ayant pas la moindre idée
de l’effet que ce fichu kava va bien
pouvoir avoir sur votre conscience.
C’est ça, [inaudible].
La situation était assurément sympathique,
tous mes voisins cracheurs étant
parfaitement gentils avec moi.
Et ça se déroule sur une île, sable
et cocotiers, au milieu du Pacifique.
C’était donc exotique.
En même temps, la situation
était totalement inquiétante,
sachant que personne ne m’a expliqué
les effets éventuels de ce kava,
et affreusement dérangeante
pour mes certitudes,
car je vous avoue qu’en général, il m’est
assez rare de cracher en groupe.
(Rires)
Ça m’arrive, mais c’est très rare.
Ce que cette manière de voyager -
le logement chez l’habitant -
m’a appris, ou plutôt m’a balancé en
pleine face, pour ne pas dire autre chose,
c’est que j’étais, moi,
pétri de certitudes.
Et cette révélation m’est venue
par la confiture.
Pas le kava, mais la confiture.
C’est toujours de la nourriture au
passage, mais ça, c’est un autre sujet.
Parce qu’il faut que
je vous annonce une chose :
le petit déjeuner sucré n’est absolument,
mais absolument, pas universel.
Le monde petit-déjeune salé.
Le concept même de trois
repas par jour assis à table
est loin d’être universel.
Dans beaucoup de pays,
y compris en Europe,
chacun mange quand il en a envie,
et les repas sont éparpillés, un peu comme
des confettis tout au long de la journée.
Dans le même ordre d’idées,
je me suis retrouvé chez un vieil homme
malade dans un petit village du Togo.
Un médecin lui avait prescrit un
médicament à prendre matin, midi et soir,
pendant les repas.
Le vieil homme n’avait rien pris,
aucun médicament,
parce que ce concept de matin,
midi et soir pendant les repas
n’avait strictement aucun sens pour lui.
Ce qui m’a bouleversé
quand j’ai découvert ces différences -
je les ai découvertes de la manière
la plus nette et profonde qui soit,
c’est-à-dire en les observant
chez les gens chez qui je vivais.
J’étais là avec eux,
c’était concret et réel.
Ce qui m’a bouleversé, c’est de constater
à quel point mes habitudes
n’étaient pas chez moi des options,
des choix culturels, non.
Mes habitudes étaient mon identité même.
Je fais trois repas par jour de la
même manière que je suis brun -
enfin, encore un peu.
Mes habitudes étaient pour moi
des conséquences intrinsèques
de l’âme humaine.
Eh bien non, pas du tout.
Alors vient le temps du combat.
Le temps du combat.
Parce que quand on fait
cette constatation, on se dit :
« Mais j’en ai combien
des habitudes de vie
qui me semblent être
dans l’ADN de l’humain,
mais qui ne le sont pas du tout ? »
Ma première intuition a été
de me dire que toutes,
absolument toutes, nos habitudes
sont uniquement culturelles,
uniquement issues du pays d'où on vient,
de notre famille, de notre époque, etc.
De la manière de dire bonjour
jusqu’à la manière de travailler,
en passant, pourquoi pas, par la manière
dont on marche, dont on parle,
tout serait interchangeable
avec d’autres habitudes.
Et nous choisirions
de garder ces habitudes
uniquement parce qu’elles permettent
la vie en commun,
elles permettent de mieux se comprendre.
On fait trois repas par jour
à des heures précises
pour ne pas nous couper
des gens qui nous entourent.
Je vais boire un petit peu d’eau.
Mais,
en continuant à voyager,
je me suis rendu compte qu’il y avait,
malgré cette intuition première,
des concepts effectivement universels.
Et j’ai décidé de faire un film
pour exprimer cette idée.
Comment dire en sons et en images
la différence entre
universel et culturel ?
Il y a un concept présenté par Nietzsche
qui donne à l’humain deux états sociaux.
En résumé, dans la vie, nous sommes
tour à tour apollonien et dionysiaque.
Apollonien la majorité du temps,
c’est-à-dire que nous présentons bien.
Nous cherchons à être le plus poli,
beau et accepté possible.
Nous portons le masque social.
Et puis, de temps en temps, plus rarement,
nous devenons dionysiaque,
c’est-à-dire que nous nous éloignons des
règles, nous retrouvons notre animalité.
On pète les plombs, on fait la fête,
on montre ses fesses, on tombe le masque.
Ces deux états sont nécessaires
l’un à l’autre,
apollonien et dyonisiaque.
Il n’y en a pas un mauvais et l’autre bon,
ils doivent être en équilibre
pour avoir une vie bonne.
Le lieu par excellence
du dionysiaque, c’est le rite,
les carnavals, les fêtes traditionnelles,
le vaudou, les mariages,
les fêtes de printemps, etc.
Ce qui est frappant,
quand on commence à analyser ces rites
qui se déroulent par milliers
dans le monde entier -
rien qu’en France,
il y en a des centaines -
c’est que les mêmes thèmes
se retrouvent partout.
Il y a les rites liés à la naissance,
comme le jet de bébé
de 10 mètres de hauteur en Inde -
de hauteur -
ou -
sur des draps -
(Rit)
ou le saut du diable au-dessus
des nouveau-nés en Espagne.
Ils sont sur des matelas,
ils sautent par-dessus.
Il y a ceux liés à l’enfance,
à l’éducation,
aux saisons, à la faim,
au soleil, à la lune,
à la crainte de la nature,
à la fécondation, à la mort,
à ce qui se passe après la mort.
Tous ces thèmes sont absolument communs
à tous les habitants de cette planète.
Il n’y a pas un endroit sur Terre
où on ne trouve pas de rites servant
à exorciser ou magnifier ces thèmes.
C’est comme si la Terre était faite
de milliers de manières
de faire avec les mêmes angoisses.
Les mêmes angoisses, faire avec.
Ce qui différencie
ces manières de faire avec,
c’est le climat où nous nous trouvons,
la géographie, la latitude,
le type de nourriture
auquel nous avons accès.
Le film, qui s’appelle « Être humain »,
dans le sens
« Qu’est-ce qu’être humain ? »,
va rebondir de rite en rite
à travers le monde
afin de relier ces rites
non par leur forme commune,
mais par leur angoisse commune,
par leur thème commun si vous préférez.
On y verra des rites très différents
célébrer exactement la même chose.
Par exemple, le feu.
En France,
on brûle de grandes tours de bois au
solstice d’été à la Saint-Jean le 21 juin,
ou on saute par-dessus le feu -
je l’ai fait quand j’étais petit -
pour célébrer le soleil
et, en même temps,
pour montrer sa puissance destructrice.
Au Salvador, les gens se jettent
des boules de feu
tous les ans, à la même date.
Dans les deux cas, la crainte
de l’énergie destructrice de la nature
est omniprésente.
Tous ces rites sur lesquels
nous posons notre vie
n’ont peut-être qu’un seul but : nous
permettre de vivre avec nos angoisses.
Juste pour ne pas terminer cette
présentation sur le mot angoisse,
(Rires)
ma conclusion sera de vous dire qu’il y a
une vraie joie, une joie rassurante
à se rendre compte que
les humains qui nous entourent,
même s'ils font des choses bizarres,
partagent avec nous le principal :
les angoisses.
Il faut que je fasse une auto-psy.
Et si, effectivement,
notre monde est fait
de milliers de cultures différentes,
ce qui nous unit,
c’est cette sorte de front commun,
cette volonté absolue de faire face.
C’est ce qui nous connecte
et nous fait être humain.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)